are we in the matrix No hi I'm Keanu
Reeves
I'm here with BuzzFeed to play with some
puppies and answer some questions thank
you let's answer some questions which
one you think this one alright what is
your secret for always staying down to
earth well I mean gravity hello
I see if you could time travel to any
period in time when would it be and why
oh my god we got puppy pee no we're not
gonna play on the puppy pee I always
wanted to know since I was growing up
who really wrote the plays of
Shakespeare so I want to I want to be
there at that moment when Shakespeare
because I don't think it was [ __ ] I'm an
Edward de verre de variants so the Earl
of Oxford so I'd like to be there 1600s
Shakespeare writing Hamlin what stunt
are you most proud of
[Music]
I don't do stunts but I try to do as
much action as I can I would say that in
the matrix the first matrix everybody
get along say I communicate alright
we're good and you're eating my shoelace
okay go ahead and eat my shoelace what
was the craziest experience you had
while filming John
craziest doing a gunfight on a horse on
the streets of Brooklyn that's in
Chapter three that was pretty crazy yep
keep going on the shoelace if you could
choose any superhero or villain to play
in the Marvel or DC Comics universe who
would it be and why I don't know when I
was a kid I always wanted to play
Wolverine
so Wolverine let's see what else do we
got what's happening buddy you are known
for your love of literature what are
some books you could recommend and
what's your favorite genre I'm gonna
pick a book that I read recently
overstory by richard powers do you think
John wick and Ted Logan would get along
why not yeah that would be an
interesting conversation maybe they
could talk about music do you share any
similarities between your character John
wick we might share a kind of drawing
sense of humor
other than that I can't really say how
much training did you do for fight
scenes in the matrix and John Waite I
did a lot of train air was really fun
the matrix the first time was learning
wire and kung fu' and that was months
and months and months and months John
wick was judo and jujitsu and a lot more
gun manipulation and there was lots and
lots and lots and lots I loved doing
action films
I loved the training I loved being here
as much as I can to create that
relationship between the character and
the audience the puppies have all left
I'm all alone if you had to live in any
of the films you've been in which one
would you choose can I visit a bunch of
them I don't want to just be in one era
it's like picking a puppy but I mean I
guess you know eventually you've got to
choose well no you could take them all
can you tell us anything about your
character in Toy Story 4 yes I played
Duke kaboom Canada's greatest stuntman
there's a lot of fun to do that film
it's a cool character it's a wonderful
story Pixar's great if you could only
have one sandwich forsaking all others
sandwiches for the rest of your life
what would that be
ah that's a tough question all right
play nice go at it what do you think
write the questions sandwich question
I'm going to pick peanut butter and
honey what advice would you give your
17-year old self I hate giving advice
how did you discover your love for
motorcycles riding them they're
beautiful riding a motorcycle is like
being a puppy isn't it that's right I
have no more questions but I have
puppies thank you very much for hanging
out
so the puppies that I got to meet today
and you got to me today are all
available for adoption thanks for
spending some time and if you go to see
John wit chapter 3 Parabellum I hope you
enjoy thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]